I heard an interview with a writer I'm
not sure it was Judy Blume the other day
it was someone on that level and and
they said that they try not to read
other writers while they're writing a
book because then their voice becomes
like their favorite writers and and so
do you often see that though for people
are really copying other people and they
don't even realize it they just know I
love that and so this is how I want it
to sound you know we we definitely live
in a culture especially in the
screenwriting world where you're
supposed to read as many scripts as you
can to learn how to write write read
read read read read but I believe
strongly in bubbles I believe you should
put mmm big magic thick plexi silent
bubble around you when you write so they
and and and the other thing you put in
your bubble is everything that you love
if you love you know bubblegum and
butterflies and unicorns or if you love
you know you know sixties music or
whatever it is you have to surround
yourself with the essence of you
and-and-and and be careful of criticism
I'm a strong believer and not allowing
any of the baby the babies that you're
writing to ever see the light of day
I've seen so many babies who've just
been born as little scripts be told that
they will never get go to college and
never grow up to be beautiful because
someone didn't get them and you think
about projects now like transcendence
and I'm sorry if you think of projects
like transparent and quirky stories
orange is the new black or where they're
deeply personal and they would never
show them they never live if the wrong
person saw that story and so be careful
and be careful of
allowing criticism be careful of
allowing other voices surround yourself
with the bubble that is authentically
you so you feel yourself you taste
yourself you smell yourself and you love
that bubble and what comes out of that
will be so much more unique and in this
world of storytelling uniqueness
authenticity authenticity originality is
what it breaks through and so that's
what you want you want to take a big
bath and you
you